[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
PETE LEPAGE: Well,
welcome everyone.
My name is Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And with me today, we have Paul
Kinlan, who is here in
London joining us.
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
PETE LEPAGE: And we're here to
talk about Chrome apps and
talk about the networking
stack.
We decided to do something a
little bit different, a little
bit fun this week.
This was actually Paul's idea
to go a little bit deep and
see if we could get a little bit
meta, do something inside
of something that normally
hasn't been done before.
So Paul, why don't you introduce
us to some of the
new networking APIs that
are available?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, cool,
so I'm Paul Kinlan.
I'm based in London.
You know Pete, you know
what we forgot to do?
PETE LEPAGE: What is that?
PAUL KINLAN: We forgot to look
at each other and high-five
each other across
the internet.
PETE LEPAGE: So we're ready.
All right.
PAUL KINLAN: Are
you good to go?
PETE LEPAGE: We're good to go.
You ready?
PAUL KINLAN: Three, two, one.
PETE LEPAGE: Two, three.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: Whoa.
OK, well, that was a complete,
total, utter fail.
But that's OK.
PAUL KINLAN: It sounded good.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
it sounded good.
And we tried.
PAUL KINLAN: We tried, right.
PETE LEPAGE: A for effort.
PAUL KINLAN: So yes, anyway,
back on the subject.
We have a new set of
APIs in Chrome.
I think in the past that we've
talked about the Chrome socket
API and space.
And one big glaring omission
from that API was the ability
to listen on port and
bind to it by UDP.
That landed a little
while ago.
So you can build a server,
which basically
receives UDP input.
And when we showed you the Air
Drone demo, about three or
four weeks ago I think, that was
using a UDP-based server.
But again, the next omission,
from this whole API, was the
ability to, actually in
JavaScript and HTML, build a
server that is TCP based
inside the browser.
So we now have the ability.
And it landed recently.
It's only experimental.
It's only in Chrome Canary
at the moment.
But we recently landed the
ability to listen and accept
API calls inside Chrome.
So what this enables you
to do is basically
build TCP based servers.
You could build an FTP server.
What we're going to talk about
today, which is a web server
that we've built and will
be available in
GitHub after the show.
Yeah, it's pretty powerful.
The fact that you can have a
web server inside your web
browser itself, inside
your applications.
I think it's been
done by Opera.
And I think Firefox has
had some stuff.
But now we've got pure access in
JavaScript to be able to do
these things.
And it's pretty exciting
inside apps.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
it definitely is.
And this is one of these things
that I don't think
really anybody's ever
done before.
And accessing these things is a
really powerful thing to be
able to do.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I'ts pretty cool, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So we were
discussing the different types
of ideas, the things
that we could do.
And you know, web server
is the first one.
The first thing that most people
try and do is a web
server inside whatever it is,
listen on port 80 or even get
the GET requests
coming back in.
But you could go even further.
You could build an
SMTP server.
And the really important thing
about these type of
the things is that--
I missed saying this before,
and should have said it
earlier on--
I think, personally, this
is really important
for Chrome OS, right?
We want the people and the
developers to be able to use
Chrome OS as a platform to
be able to develop web
applications and applications
in general.
And I think one of the things
that has generally been
missing is this ability to, when
you're offline, connect
to a local instance of a web
server, build your application
locally, your website locally,
connect to it, and test it
inside the browser.
And I think this API, this
single API, the listen and
accept APIs in the socket
interface, they allow us to do
those types of things.
It's going to be pretty cool
in the future to see what
comes out on this.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
Go ahead.
PAUL KINLAN: Should we jump to
a demo, just to prove it does
work, and I'm not lying and
bringing everyone on?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I
think we should.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
PETE LEPAGE: All right, so
we've got your screen up.
People can see your screen.
PAUL KINLAN: Yay.
This is my app.
It's like a semi standalone
application build with the
Chrome app APIs.
And what it allows us to do--
and I'll just reload it,
because I was testing
it before.
Never say I never
come prepared.
I was testing it before.
So pick a file.
And it's this directory here,
this app directory that I want
to serve from my local machine,
to obviously local
connections.
Press Select, Start.
So the interesting thing
about this, and I
think I kind of like--
oh, there's a big list of files
it can actually serve.
I've used the normal input type
equals file attribute--
method, sorry.
Is it method?
PETE LEPAGE: The directory?
PAUL KINLAN: HTML tag.
Yeah, the HTML5 tag, input type
equals file, with WebKit
Directory, so I can select
directories.
That returns, obviously, an
on-change It gives us access
to the list of files that
we've selected.
And I basically just take a
reference to those file
references.
And then I'll serve them
in the web or locally.
So 127, there we go.
That's it.
It's kind of simple, Wotcha!
Now live.
This is an application
I made with Yeoman
in about two seconds.
PETE LEPAGE: Whoohoo.
PAUL KINLAN: Nice little
plug to Yeoman.
But it's the basic application,
right?
It's not styled up.
But the interesting thing is if
we go to Inspect Element--
let me just detach that so we
can see it inside the screen.
PETE LEPAGE: And just to mention
this, for folks who
are interested, if they want
to check out the code for
this, they can go to the
URL on the screen.
You can go download the sample
at goo.gl/AZSTg.
And you can see that
capitalization and all that
stuff there.
But, all right, sorry.
Go ahead, Paul.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
that's cool.
So we just push stuff to GitHub,
so people can off and
experiment with it now.
The caveat is, it's still
experimental.
So you need to enable
experimental
APIs and about flags.
And it's also only available
in Canary.
But once you enable those
two things, you can
actually play this API.
And if you look here,
this is the code.
Sorry, not the code.
Sorry, this is the list of
requests, just to prove that
I'm actually making
those requests
from my local resource--
script score slash vendor, for
instance, forward slash
modernizer dot min dot JS.
That's being served off
of my local file
system via this interface.
So it's pretty cool.
It's pretty powerful.
And we're going to show
you actually how
to build these things--
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet.
PAUL KINLAN: Today.
So should we jump into code?
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: So, as we can see
here, everybody who can see my
screen, the first thing that
we need to do when we're
building this application, is
actually change the manifest.
The reason why we need to do
this, and I should've gotten
rid of this earlier on, is by
default we don't normally have
experimental permissions enabled
inside our manifest.
So if I just select this and
see this here, you add
experimental.
This will enable your access
to the advanced socket API.
You then ask for a socket
permission.
And this is relatively
new syntax.
It landed maybe about
a month ago.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: But it allows you
to basically say and list
different types of permissions
that you want the socket
interface to have inside
your application.
So if you're going to do UDP
server or send UDP requests
out from your client
applications or remote server,
you need to actually specify
this up front, so that the
user, when they install this
application, they know the
types of interactions with your
native operating system
that you're going to have.
And in this case--
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I was going to say, Paul, so
if I want to send UDP, I'm
guessing it's probably not UDP
connect and UDP listen is it?
PAUL KINLAN: No it's not.
It's UDP sendto, I believe.
And it will be UDP bind.
PETE LEPAGE: UDP sendto to send
packets, and then UDP
bind will allow you to bind to
a port to listen for next
stuff coming in?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
And the sytax can get a little
bit more complex.
So you can basically, in theory,
bind to just a single
address on a special port.
And what this is basically
trying to say to do here is,
well, if you say TCP listen,
your application could bind to
any port on the user's system.
I believe it's not under the
root's permissions, so
anything below.
1024, I think you can't
bind to, but anything
above that you can.
But when you're doing a UDP
send or a TCP connect, in
theory, you could connect
to port 22 for TELNET
and port 80 for HTTP.
You just want to let the user
know, for instance, those
types of services.
I'm going to give them that
little bit of extra trust that
they get when they know the
only things that they can
access are the things you've
listed up front.
But anyway, back on topic.
The most important thing
here is TCP listen.
This is the new experimental
permission that you need for
the socket interface to be able
to listen to ports and
listen to incoming requests.
So if you add this in and you've
already got a socket
based application, you
should be good to go.
Now that doesn't mean that--
sorry--
doesn't mean, straight away,
that you're going be able to
start taking requests.
Obviously you have to
program the API.
So I just want to show you, just
to prove that all this is
the same thing.
Ignore this styling stuff.
But let me go to the next
input type equals file.
This is the HTML that's
involved in actually
constructing our
user interface.
Input type equals file with an
attribute of WebKit Directory
and just an ID called
directory.
Now the reason why I do WebKit
Directory is, if you've never
actually done this before,
normally, input type equals
file only allows you to
select one file from
the user's file system.
If you do input type equals
file under a multiple
attribute, then you can select
multiple files on the user's
system and get it brought back
into your application.
But if you do WebKit Directory,
WebKit Directory
basically gives you the entire
list of files inside the
directory that the
user's selected.
So we went to the app demo
before, and we saw the fact
that I selected the app folder,
everything inside that
folder is now available
to my application
to be able to read.
You can't write to those
applications.
That's actually a subject for
another Hangout altogether is
how to write to these files
and actually you can get
access to them once you've
got a reference to it.
But now it's only read-only.
And to be fair, that's kind of
all we really need for our
basic web service--
to be able to read files that
are contained in a directory
that the user has chosen and
granted you access to.
So anyway, let's jump
into the code.
index.js is where it lives.
And as you can see, I've already
got a whole lot of
boilerplate.
I mean a lot of this code is
actually just hooking up the
user interface elements and
then also doing stream
conversions.
Because the interesting things
to know about the socket API
is it sends array
buffer objects.
And the array buffer object is
not something that we normally
deal with inside JavaScript.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we're not
used to that at all.
So what's the difference between
an array buffer and a
string, if I haven't really
played with those before?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes, so the main
difference between an array
buffer and a string,
essentially, is the fact that,
if you have ever done any kind
of boundary manipulation on
the string inside JavaScript,
you know how hard is it.
You have to take the high order
byte and the lower order
byte, because it's
UTF16, I think.
And you have to do a whole lot
of manipulation just to access
the core data.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And the array
buffer allows you to have
multiple different types of
views on a piece of data.
So you can say my entire data,
that's contained in array
buffer, is of UInt array type or
UInt8 array, UInt16 array,
UInt32 array.
So you can say your array is
of different types of data.
But, essentially, what it allows
you to do is say, well,
my view on this array buffer is
an array of 8 bit integers,
essentially.
And that allows you to then
say, well, we just read
through the bytes
individually.
So as you can see here, if we
go here, the view, we got a
new array based on the array
buffer of type UInt8 array.
And then we just iterate across
it and, basically,
convert our string.
So we convert our string
into UInt8 array.
So its written across our string
and then pushing that
value that's held in the array,
directly into the
actual array buffer itself.
PETE LEPAGE: Perfect.
PAUL KINLAN: And that's cool,
because then you can handle
big endian and little endian,
when you try and deliver data.
It's super important for the
socket API, because the
majority of time we're not
really sending strings around.
When doing a web socket, for
instance, you might want to
send a string, because
it's an adjacent
structure and that's fine.
But actually, at the raw level
for the socket API, you send
raw binary data.
And that's why we need these
extra little functions.
We also have an array buffer to
string, which we just used
to basically convert, obviously,
an array buffer,
the data that we receive back
from the service to a string.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: And the reason
why we use this is that we
have to parse out, for instance,
when an HTTP request
comes in, there's a very
specific set of headers that
you get through.
And passing in binary, actually
byte by byte, is just
a bit of a pain.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So I convert
it to a string and do
some work onto it.
You'll see that there's
probably a big glaring
security hole in it, where I
just read the whole string.
And if you send a big enough
set of headers, like 1,000
megabytes or gigabytes of
headers, my application will
probably crash.
But just to demonstrate the
purpose of this, like I said
to you guys, we're ignoring
all of that type of stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
And I think that's one other
thing to point out.
We wrote this as a really quick
sample, not as something
that is meant to be used as a
key thing that you should copy
everything from and sit
down and write a web
server using this.
We just wanted to sort of get
some of the concepts across.
And there's a few things we
could have done better.
A few things we could
have done worse.
PAUL KINLAN: I mean the demo's
only going to show you how to
handle get requests.
So if you want to do cross
origin and post puts and
everything else, that's not
going to work at the moment.
But the concept is there.
You can build a web server
entirely in JavaScript that
lives inside your browser.
The place I always like this,
and I don't think they're ever
going to do it, but the App
Engine SDK uploader.
You kind of get your
dev environment.
You can basically run Python
with mscript and whatever
other technologies
you want to use.
You can have the App Engine's
mini system just run inside
the browser and upload.
That's where I'd like to get
to in 10 year's time.
Actually, in 10 year's time,
I'd like to be retired and
living on the beach somewhere.
PETE LEPAGE: Well, yeah.
Well, how about then, in nine
years time, you get that done.
And then in 10 years, you can
retire, because everybody just
thinks that's so awesome and
they just make it happen.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I think that's good.
I think that's really good.
Should we do it?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Let's do it.
Done.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
Let's ship it.
I have to say, I'm not
pre-announcing anything.
So anyway, on that subject.
So let's just jump through
the code, right.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: This is before
the nitty-gritty, right.
I just want to show you the
rest of the infrastructure
that I've got ready
for you guys.
They are doing dot onchange.
It's not the nicest way
that we handle events.
But we're only going
to bind to it once.
And I just thought, for brevity,
it was going to be
easier for everyone
to understand.
When the user actually picks
a directory, we get
the onchange event.
In that onchange, we can get
an access to list of files
done by this little line of
code, line 58, e.target.files.
That's a list of files inside
the directory that the user
has chosen.
We just iterate across them.
We take the Web Kit relative
path, which gives us,
basically, a relative path.
It doesn't give us the full
directory structure, just the
root of where it is,
which is absolutely
fine for a web server.
Because we only ever deal,
really, with absolute paths
inside our own web app.
And then we just map that.
We take the path, map it into,
basically, a hash.
So that whenever a web request
comes in, I can then go and
easily pick the file up from my
in memory store and serve
that back out to the user.
So that's all there is from
actually getting access to the
file system.
It's not the full file system.
It's just the directory and all
the subdirectories that
the user has chosen.
But we can do some
nice things.
We can kind of serve them up
inside our application.
PETE LEPAGE: And to be clear,
this is the HTML5 file system,
or is this the file
system access that
comes with Chrome app?
PAUL KINLAN: No, no.
It's neither actually.
Eh.
So we have a couple different
types of file systems living
in the user's device,
basically.
We have the HTML5 file system,
which is entirely sandboxed
and only available to the
application, in that domain,
and all the files are obfuscated
and a whole lot of
other stuff so can't go and
easily parse the files out on
the user's local machine.
We also have--
what was the second
one you asked?
PETE LEPAGE: The Chrome
apps file system.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so we have
the Chrome apps file system.
I tell you what.
It's similar to the Chrome
apps file system API.
The Chrome apps file system API
and the media gallery API
essentially allow you to get
elevated access to those
directories.
So if you're using the file
system API, you can basically
say, well, the user's given
me a file, and I've got a
reference to that.
I want to write back to it.
And we don't need that in our
application, so we're not
using that part of the API.
But it's using the same file
object that you get back from
the system.
This is literally the user's
own file system itself.
So it's pretty cool.
It's just a file system, but
it's only the directory that
they've actually given
you access to.
So let's actually get into
the code, right.
Start the onclick.
This is the thing that's going
to start the server.
So it's pretty simple, right?
We've already got the
permissions ready.
So we're going to not call it
Isocket, because that's me
being silly with vim.
We're going to create a socket
of TCP type, with no extra
information supplied.
And then just take a function
call back, and call it
socketInfo.
So this is the very start of the
thing that most people do
when they're building a
socket-based interface or an
application, is they need
to create the socket.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: So we need to do
a little bit more that that,
because that's not actually
doing anything.
For ease of use later on, I'm
going to bind the socket
information that we get
to a global variable.
Again, it's not the best type of
code, but it's just simple.
It works.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
We're going to then operate our
socket to a server socket.
So we're going to say, listen.
And if we do listen--
oh god, sorry, I apologize.
socketInfo.socketID.
This is basically saying, for
the socket that we've just
created, we're going to turn
it into a server socket.
It doesn't mean much yet,
because we haven't got an
address to bind it to.
I'm just going to bind it to
local host on port 8081.
This is untested now.
So 8081, just to prove
that my demo later
on is going to work.
And we're going to allow
20 requests to come
through at a time.
So that's pretty much all you
have to do to get started to
make it into a server socket.
But the thing is, it's not that
interesting once you do that.
You basically want to get
notification that it's all
worked and everything is fine.
So if we've done it right,
console.log, I don't know,
listening, listen-- you
know, I can't spell.
I've found, in the past three
weeks, that my spelling is
absolutely atrocious.
I just noticed a spelling
mistake, result.
So basically the console will
just log the fact that we made
a connection and everything's
fine.
If it's not fine, we'll get an
error here and an exception.
So we won't be able to
do anything else.
And now what we need to do is be
able to start to listen and
accept our first connection
coming in.
So let's just go over this a
little bit, because there's a
lot that's going on,
in a relatively
short amount of time.
So in this case, we've made
our socket, created it.
It's there.
It's ready.
The system knows about it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: And then we've
just said, listen.
So the idea here normally is,
in a client application, you
do connect.
You create a socket and then
you connect to a remote
service or you send some
data via a UDP request.
That's not what we're doing.
That's a client application.
This is service application,
a server application.
So we're just saying listen on
port-- well, listen on IP
address 127.0.0.1
on port 8081.
Now I've hard coded in 127,
just because it just
illustrates the point.
You can actually get a list of
the network interfaces and let
the user choose which
IP address.
PETE LEPAGE: Which IP address
they want or which network
adapter they want
to listen on.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, essentially,
yeah.
So that then lets you
get the IP address.
And then you can listen on a
public IP address if your
browser was--
PETE LEPAGE: Multi-homed or
something like that, yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: But I mean
normally, if you've got a
local network and you want to
try connect to it, then you
can bind to your Ethernet card
or your WiFi adapter and then
have the requests come in.
PETE LEPAGE: Well this could be
an interesting scenario for
those people who want to write
a proxy server at home-- and
have a proxy server sit at home,
that they could go and
just basically write something
that proxies out network
connections effectively.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, you could
actually do that.
That's actually pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, and that's
all done by JavaScript HTML.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
So one of things I want to call
out here that, when I
first started writing some of
these network connection
things, it took me a second to
go, oh, great, I love this.
You do get into a bit of
call back fun, right?
So on the create, it actually
has a call back that says,
once it's created, call
this function.
Then, once you've created the
socket, then you actually have
to tell the socket what to do.
So you actually have to go
and work with a couple of
different pieces.
So when you look at this,
remember, to think through,
OK, what's this call
back going to do?
How's this going to work,
in each of these pieces?
PAUL KINLAN: I think that's the
important thing, right?
We're just using the call backs
here because it keeps
everything in one lump.
You probably want
to do a bind.
And you basically just pass
everything, like marginalize
your JavaScript a little
better than
we're going to do today.
Basically just bind and let the
the object and scope flow
through to function calls .
The interesting thing is that
this is a common problem that
JavaScript developers do.
And if you're using Node, for
instance, there's a whole of
NPM modules, which I try to make
asynchronous call back
management a lot easier.
Can I call that an
open challenge?
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know.
I don't know how I'm going
to do this just yet.
But I would absolutely love to
see, now that we're getting
some parity between the features
and functionality
available on Node.js, is if we
can leverage some of the
functionality that people have
built in to Node, whether it's
connect, even like the web
socket servers and all this
type of stuff.
All these functions, if we can
write in a light wrapper
around the APIs that are in
Node, that will be brilliant.
If you just get them imported
into Chrome.
And then we've got a similar
ecosystem across the server
and then also across
the browser.
What you know is your server
inside the browser, which on
the client would be
pretty powerful.
And then we've got big ecosystem
of application
functionality then available
to developers.
PETE LEPAGE: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: It would be cool.
Get Meteor on.
That would be brilliant, Meteor
in the browser talking
to the browser.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: Sweet.
Yeah, I was going to say I'll
buy someone an Nexus
7 if they do that.
But I don't think I'm
allowed to say that.
PETE LEPAGE: No, probably not.
Well, unless you wanted to buy
yourself an extra set--
PAUL KINLAN: I would buy
it myself, actually.
If someone did it, and they did
it I'd buy them a Nexus 7.
PETE LEPAGE: So just to be
clear, it's not a promise.
But I think if they show
something pretty cool, I think
there might be some good
recognition for them.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
Definitely.
PETE LEPAGE: All right, so let's
hop back into this code.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I'm trying
to work out how much trouble
that we're going to be in.
Well, I'm going to be in now.
PETE LEPAGE: Eh.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's
jump in, right.
So we got the connection.
And I'm really sorry
about going up and
down through the code.
I just made a little
mistake then.
So I'll just jump in, right.
Let's split the window, so
you can see the code.
This is why I like
vim It's cool.
But also your preferred text
editor is also cool.
I'm not going to get into
a war about this.
PETE LEPAGE: I was
going to say, I
think Sublime is awesome.
But you know.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, I know.
PETE LEPAGE: Whatever
floats your boat.
Actually while you get yourself
set up there, I do
want to mention one
thing real quick.
If people who are watching this
have questions, they want
to know maybe a little bit
deeper, please post your
questions on Moderator.
The link is there on
screen right now.
You can just go to Moderator
and post a few questions.
And we'll take those questions
as we get towards the end of
the session today.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, that's
pretty cool.
We've got one or two--
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, we got
a couple good ones.
PAUL KINLAN: Which we will be
able to answer as well.
They're going to be good.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
So stay tuned.
PAUL KINLAN: Let's go
back to the code.
I apologize, two
seconds, again.
Hey.
PETE LEPAGE: 1, 1,000,
2, 1,000.
I'm going to give you trouble.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, dude.
I'm ready.
Don't worry.
PETE LEPAGE: All right,
all you then.
PAUL KINLAN: I was adding
to the suspense.
So we talked about it before,
socket.accept.
accept takes a connection that's
come in, off the queue,
and then allows you
to process it.
So in theory, we
have this here.
So we say, I need to accept the
connection that's coming
from the particular socket
that we've created.
And there's a call back
called onaccept.
And we're going to jump
to onaccept now
and fill that out.
Because what actually happens
is kind of interesting.
It's part of the API.
And it's something that I found
a little bit confusing,
when I first played with
it, is you can
only call accept once.
And you can only process
one request that's
come in at a time.
So it's very single threaded
in this sense.
So if you're doing a whole lot
of processing and someone's
uploaded a big file to your
socket, then what you should
really do is try and delegate
that work off to a web worker
or something similar to that,
very much like you do in Node,
essentially, just maintain the
asychrononicity at least.
onaccept is the call back that
happens when we know we've got
some data that's come back in.
So the very first time we do
this, there's going to be
nothing happening.
Because I haven't gone back
to my browser and
actually made a request.
When I do make a request,
onaccept will be called.
And what we need to do is we
need to jump up to my previous
window and start filling
this out.
Now what we do here is,
actually, we read the data
from the socket into
our application.
I mean, we don't have to.
But otherwise, it would
be a pretty rubbish
application, right?
So what we're going to do is
we're going to call a simple--
and there's a lot
of code in here.
So please follow along.
It's going to be
a bit awkward.
So acceptInfo.socketID
function readInfo.
And this is where you're going
to see all the call backs that
we mentioned earlier on.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh goody.
Oh goody.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
it's awesome.
So what we've done here is, now
that we know that we've
been called, a connection has
been made to our server, we
say, we'll need to read
from the socket.
Notice how we are using
acceptInfo socket, not
socketInfo as the variable.
This is because the actual
request that's come in
basically isn't on the same
socket as the one that you're
listening on.
The way that underlined system
works is it delegates it back
off to the system.
And there's a separate channel
that enables you to
communicate back
to the service.
So we've got a different
socket.
So that's fine.
We'll read through it.
We call a read.
And, in theory, what you'd
see here now is--
I'm just going to put
it in so we know--
is you would see all the data
that's come back in.
readInfo itself has got
a data property.
So let's just get it off.
Actually, let's convert
it to a string first.
arrayBufferToString.
And this is a function that
I've made myself.
It's not in the call
library system.
But there we go, right.
So the idea behind this now is
that we've gone through, got
the data out, called
arrayBufferToString, which is here.
We basically take the
array buffer,
convert it to a string.
And the reason why we
do this is because--
wait for it--
PETE LEPAGE: I'm waiting.
I'm waiting.
PAUL KINLAN: We need
to read from it.
So what I do is I say-- yeah,
it's exciting-- indexOf.
So we need to find the very
first part of the string.
I'm going to put a
space in there,
because it could be wrong.
Equals 0.
And this is basically the HTTP
header that we've got back in.
So we are reading from
the request.
We're assuming that it's
a HTTP request.
When it is a HTTP request, the
very first set of characters
in the string are the
actual method
that's going to be called.
Not the underlined method, but
the post, get, put, delete,
all those types things.
And in this case, we're
just going to look
for the word, get.
We're not going to handle
anything else.
That's pretty cool.
So if we get the word, get,
there, there's a strong
likelihood, at least, that the
data is a HTTP request.
So let's parse it a
little bit more.
And I'm going to take a whole
lot of liberties with this.
We're going to get the
end of the URI.
So the thing that comes after
the get request--
and I'm sorry for doing
an HTTP 101 here--
is actually the URL that
you're fetching.
So just substring uriEnd.
So we're just going
to parse this out.
And we're going to just assume
that it all works.
And we're then going to get
the file from filesMap.
That's what we said before.
When we clicked on the
directory, like the file
picker button we have
the ability
to select the directory.
We take all those files in that
directory and store them
in a hash with the URL,
basically, of
the local file system.
And then we map that
on, using this.
So what we'll see here is, if
a web request comes into our
server, forward slash index
dot HTML, we'll see that.
We'll get the URI out.
And then we'll look for a file
called index dot HTML in our
memory collection of files.
Which is pretty cool.
And then this is going to
look silly, because it
doesn't exist yet.
But write response is a function
that we've made.
Info.socketId file.
This is just a function
that we've made.
And we're going to
go to it now.
PETE LEPAGE: So before
you pop down there.
Where you've got your file,
when you went to hit your
semicolon, you actually
got an A in there, at
the end of that line.
PAUL KINLAN: Dude, thank
you very much.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow,
now we got an R.
PAUL KINLAN: It's gone now.
It should be there.
PETE LEPAGE: Now
write200Response.
Now why is it write200Response
versus writeResponse?
PAUL KINLAN: Basically, it was
just the way I decided to try
and structure the application.
I was going to say that, if I
can't find the file, I would
try and write a 400 response,
going out.
From the verbosity of it, it
made sense when I was looking
at it, just to say
write200Response.
writeResponse with a status code
would probably be better.
PETE LEPAGE: Fair enough.
OK.
PAUL KINLAN: No, we
can refer to this.
And if anyone wants to take the
code, fork it, and make it
look a lot nicer, then
super-fine by me.
PETE LEPAGE: That would
be super cool.
PAUL KINLAN: This
is our function.
We take the socketID.
So the socketID, this is the
network socket the network
port that we're going to write
back to the client, write back
to the web browser
with the data on.
So we have the file.
We're going to work out
the contentType.
Luckily the file object, in
a lot of cases, has the
contentType on.
I'd just assume that, if the
contentType doesn't exist,
it's called text plain.
That's probably not the best
assumption, but it was
reasonable.
contentLength, you're a good
web citizen if put the
contentLength on.
So we get the file size.
So the actual size of the
file is stored in
the file system object.
It's pretty cool.
And then we do this thing
called header.
We make a header.
And the reason why is because,
when you do a network
response, you have to put a
HTTP header at the top.
And then you also, at the
bottom, you have to then put
the file contents.
And the HTTP header basically
says what type of protocol
you're using, whether
it's HTTP1, 1.1.
The status code, 200
in this case--
200 is success and
the word, OK.
And then some extra
information, like
contentLength and contentType.
Now we're using the inverse
of a stringToArrayBuffer--
oh sorry.
PETE LEPAGE:arrayToStringBuffer.
We're using stringToArrayBuffer.
PAUL KINLAN: We're now making
an array buffer.
So it's converting this single
string that we've got, which
is a collection of the header
information, essentially.
Two, we're take basically taking
that data, making an
array buffer, so that we can
send that out to the client.
Now the interesting thing, and
the way I've done this-- and
it's probably not the best
way, again-- is I've just
assumed that I want to
glob all the data--
the header and the response--
into one write.
I don't have to do that.
I probably shouldn't
do that that way.
Anyway you have an output
buffer, which is the
combination of the HTTP header
and the actual file body
itself, the raw file data that
we're going to pull back in.
Now we have this.
Excuse me.
So we have the view.
The view is basically just the
way that you can actually put
data into an array buffer.
You can't put data into an array
buffer directly, so we
have to do some work.
The array buffer itself
is the header length
plus the file length.
We put the header at the very
start of the array buffer,
which is what you need.
And then we need to put
the body at the end.
Now the interesting thing
here is, this is the
asynchronous bit again.
You have to use the HTML5 file
reader API, because we've got
a file object.
We don't have access
to the bytes.
We need to basically ask the
system to give us that
information.
So we use the file reader
API, in this case.
It's one single call,
fileReader, listen to onload,
so that we know that the file's
been loaded up and is
all ready to go.
And we then, finally say,
readAsArrayBuffer.
So the file object can be
returned is an array buffer.
And the idea behind what we're
going to do now is once the
file data's come in, we're going
to stuff that into the
array buffer itself, right at
the end, after the header.
So we have this one big glob of
data that we're just going
to send out to the client.
PETE LEPAGE: So Paul, one of the
things, if someone wanted
to refactor this, one way they
could do it, to make it
potentially a much faster web
server, is on start up, when
it reads that directory,
depending on how many files
there are, it could load all
of those files into memory.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: And then just keep
them there, so that it
just always was able to
immediately respond with them
and have them--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, so I mean it
seems a little heavyweight
to do what we're doing
right now, honestly.
But it's just there
to show the point.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: But the other
thing, as well, is you can
actually do two socket writes,
sending the data
back over the socket.
You could do two writes.
You could write the header
and then write
the body just after.
That's like two asynchronous
calls.
It's a little bit harder to
orchestrate, but then we don't
have to block the user interface
on trying to
construct these two larger
objects together.
PETE LEPAGE: Though admittedly,
in this app, there
isn't much of a user
interface.
So blocking on that would
not be a huge deal.
But you still don't
want to do that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, exactly.
So let's go and see where
we can go from here.
So we want to do the
socket.write.
So we're going to write to the
socket, write the data from
the file system API to
the web, essentially.
It's pretty cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: And this should
be simple socketId
outputBuffer--
be careful how I spell
that one out--
function writeInfo.
And again, another nice,
very cute call back.
PETE LEPAGE: Ah, got to
love those call backs.
PAUL KINLAN: I believe
that is not needed.
And in theory, that's
it, right?
But we want a little bit
more information.
So we've taken the data and
we constructed the header
response and also the
body response.
And we've written it
out in one go.
To be a good citizen, actually,
what we need to do
is actually destroy
the socket.
So one of the things I found
out, when I was doing this is
the number of sockets, if you
don't destroy them, once
you've finished the connection,
and you've written
the data out, and you're happy
that the client's got the
data, the application will
probably crash at some point
in the future.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, because
there are a
limited number of sockets.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
essentially.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, do you
need to destroy and
close or just destroy?
PAUL KINLAN: You might
need to close.
I just did destroy, and
it seems to work.
I should probably be a
better citizen and
also close it as well.
But what I'm doing here, this
is the thing that got me
before when I was
starting this.
Because overall, it took me
about an hour and a half to
make this whole application.
It's pretty cool.
socket.accept, you need to
call that again, because
you've handled the request.
You basically need to tell the
system that you want to pick
off the next request again.
Because you can only have
one of those in flight.
I chose to do it in this type of
queue here, because you can
only have one in flight.
I need to know that what we've
done has completed
successfully, in which
case it's the write.
And, in theory--
oh, tell you what.
That should be it.
Let me just go to the end.
I know there's a Stop button.
We should also do socket.destroy
to kill the
server socket.
oh, info.socketId.
And that is all we actually
need to do.
We have our server.
Shall we test it?
PETE LEPAGE: Let's test it.
PAUL KINLAN: Should
we test it live?
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: So I have an
extension web server file.
It's not that one.
And it's not that one.
That was my test.
That was one of my
other tests.
Hey, funny.
PETE LEPAGE: There you go.
PAUL KINLAN: So it hasn't
crashed yet.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet.
PAUL KINLAN: Launch.
Shall we see if there's
any errors?
No errors so far.
Choose files.
Choose that app directory.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
Nice.
PAUL KINLAN: No errors.
Start.
No errors.
Oh.
PETE LEPAGE: No whammies,
no whammies,
no whammy, no whammy.
PAUL KINLAN: 81, because--
yay!
It worked.
PETE LEPAGE: Congratulations.
Nice job, sir.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh my.
That's it, right.
That's the whole basic premise
of what we're trying to do
with this, in like 30 minutes.
And we've gone through this.
And we talked an obviously
long time here.
We built a basic server that
allows you to serve data from
your local machine, your local
Chrome OS box, your MacBook,
all those types of things, serve
it directly to the user.
Offline, online, however you
want to do it, you can do it.
Obviously, it's a very
simple server.
It only handles get requests.
It doesn't do pokes and all
that type of stuff.
But you can see what's
going to happen.
And like I said, if you can
get some of the Node based
spaces, like the server work,
a lot of people have already
done in that whole ecosystem.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I know there's
quite a bit of mapping that
needs to be done, because
there's a buffer, which is
different to our array buffer
and all that type of stuff.
So there needs to be some
marshalling and munging in
between the two bits there.
And I think it's one of the
things, like it would be so
cool if you could test your
entire stack without
necessarily having to have
Node.js sever installed.
On your MacBook Pro and your
Windows machine, you'll have
that on anyway.
But if you've got a Chrome OS
box, right now, it's like--
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
PAUL KINLAN: That would
be pretty sweet.
You could start to test out your
Node based application,
inside the browser, from
your Chrome OS machine.
PETE LEPAGE: Or you could,
effectively, go and just do
any of the development that you
want to do on your Chrome
Book and have a server
running locally.
So I just put the URL
for the network
documentation up on screen.
So if you want to dive into this
a little bit deeper, you
can see the URL there.
And that'll take you to the
Chrome apps documentation,
where all of this stuff goes
into much more detail, all of
the different APIs the connect,
the destroy, the
close, all of those fun
things that you do
need to know about.
PAUL KINLAN: The--
I'm sorry.
PETE LEPAGE: No, go ahead.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, the thing I'd
just like to say is that
this API is pretty cool.
It's very powerful.
It's something that we've
not seen inside
Chrome before, at least.
But the thing for me is it's
going to enable so
many more use cases.
It's going to be really cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Personally, I'd
like more high level APIs.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: So if someone could
make like and FTP API or
DNS API and all those different
types of APIs that
other developers can just use
and say, you know what?
I want to connect to an FTP
client or an FTP service.
Or I want to make it
my own FTP service.
And it just works.
PETE LEPAGE: Abolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: I'd love
that to happen.
That would be absolutely
brilliant.
PETE LEPAGE: So actually that's
a perfect segue into
some of the questions.
Because one of the first
questions that's in there is,
could you summarize, at a high
level, what the new use cases
you see in enabling
in our apps are?
Any particular use cases
that you want to see?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: So I know for me,
there's a couple that I've
been playing with lately.
Things like there's a little box
that you can buy called an
IP to IR converter.
And I've just been playing
with this.
I know it's completely dorky.
So it plugs into your
network port.
And then it's got IR
blasters on it.
So you can then use that to
control your TV, your anything
that's controlled via IR.
So I'm working on writing a
little Chrome app that will
allow me to turn my air
conditioner on and off, will
allow me to turn the TV on and
off, do all sorts of crazy
little things like that.
So that's one case.
But other things are being able
to write servers, like we
talked about, being able to
go and communicate with
appliances that you normally
wouldn't be able to
communicate with.
What are some of the ones that
you're excited about, Paul?
PAUL KINLAN: Use cases
or appliances?
PETE LEPAGE: Both.
PAUL KINLAN: Both.
Appliances, ah, so many.
I really like the idea--
so we got a demo
for the Media Center.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: I want to be able
to access all my media around
my house, brings into
my Chrome app.
And if I go on a plane, I can
just download it straight to
my Chrome Book and still
play and listen to it.
It's pretty cool.
So we've got that
type of demo.
That type of interaction is
something you just don't get
in the browser, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Right now.
And it's pretty cool.
Some of the other stuff, so
services, in an actual way,
this is important for me.
You know, literally, I want us
to be able to build services
and services in our
applications.
I think one of the questions
is I should've built a Bit
Torrent client.
Yeah, we can build a
Bit Torrent client.
I just don't know
how to do it.
I don't know the protocol.
It probably would've been a
bit longer than this talk.
But yeah, those are the types of
things that we are enabled
to do now, in the sense
that we can have
a Bit Torrent client.
And you could, in theory, just
open ports that you need to
listen to the requests coming in
to share the data back out.
And so you could quite easily do
it-- well, sort of easily.
The API is there for you
to be able do that.
That would be pretty cool.
FTP services, FTP servers,
FTP clients.
You know, there's so many people
who still actually use
FTP, a lot of web developers
who use FTP.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: Not even FTPS, just
plain FTP to get the data
around places and up
on the web host,
those types of things.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: I was actually
thinking it might have been
cool for like a cURL
on the web.
You always see these things,
like cURL on the web, where
you don't serve it, necessarily,
but like a normal
client request.
Just debug the HTTP
requests, without
having to go into DevTools.
You can just put it all in.
And you don't need the remote
server to do it.
You can do all type of stuff.
The interesting thing, we don't
have any access to the
really, really low layers
of the API.
So you can't do pings.
Like [INAUDIBLE] stuff,
you can't do.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: But
you can do DNS.
DNS clients, I want a whole load
of APIs available, high
level APIs available.
Let me just fire off
a DNS request or a
network time request.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And all these types
of things would be cool.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
And then we can build
some really cool
applications on it.
The first one that always comes
to mind-- and this is I
think why we did the web
developer, kind of the web
server, is because this is
something web developers want
to be able to do on their
Chrome Books.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
PAUL KINLAN: So I think
we can enable that.
And it would be pretty cool if
someone like Cloud Nine or
someone else comes along and
says, yeah, we can do that
while you're offline.
That would be cool.
PETE LEPAGE: We'll pop that
into our development
environment.
So Louise, from Phoenix, wants
to know is there a way to do a
broadcast to find other servers
to use this for
LAN-based HTML5 game servers?
And the answer is, yes.
Right now, there's a bug
with UDP listen on
the broadcast port.
So that's not going to work.
And the engineers are aware
of that, and they're
looking into that one.
But you can, certainly, once
that gets fixed, you'll be
able to listen for UDP
broadcasts sent out.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, our Media
Gallery sample on GitHub--
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
That actually does that
type of thing.
But it's a little bit broken
at the moment.
The thing it does, it basically
fires off of, I
think, it's 239.245.255's
address.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Which is like the
UDP broadcast, essentially,
for DNLA discovery.
And then basically, you
will fire that off.
That's fired and you can do
the broadcast, but at the
other end, you need to
be able to listen.
And like Pete said,
that API did work.
But I think someone stopped
working recently.
But should be able to find--
do a UDP bind to port 0 and
then receive all these
responses back in.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And that
should all work.
PETE LEPAGE: So we've got
another question of, how many
requests can it handle
at a time?
If you have to destroy and start
accepting again, does
that mean you can only accept
one request at a time?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes is the answer
right now, only one
request at a time.
But if you look at the way Node
works, its relatively
similar, right?
I mean Node only processes
one request.
It trys to then delegate the
rest of the functionality to
other asynchronous parts of
the system, then handle
responses that way.
And if you look at the Python
Tornado server, it was a
similar thing.
You could only handle one
request at a time coming in.
So yeah, right now, that's
the only way you
can do it just yet.
The idea is that you would
take the request.
And you'd background it.
I mean all these APIs
are asynchronous.
So we might actually be
able to take multiple
ones, earlier on.
I'm trying to think how
the accept works now.
I haven't actually tested it
with trying to delegate these,
like finish the accept
off really early.
So just say, you know what, we
finished with the accept, go
off and do whatever you want.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: I haven't
tried that just yet.
But right now it's
one at a time.
It's pretty speedy for what
we're trying to do as basic
file serving.
PETE LEPAGE: This is something
that I think works perfectly
for a development environment
or a little test environment
or maybe something you want to
write for controlling of an
application like the IP to IR
controller, where you're only
going to have a couple people
connecting to it at any time.
You're not going to have
the entire world.
It's not designed, in this
particular case, to scale.
Now you absolutely could write
scale with this stuff.
But the way we've written
it won't scale well.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
The way I've written this
application it probably won't
scale well at all.
I think it's a very
general API.
It's the POSIX socket
API essentially.
So we can build systems that
scale quite easily.
This literally landed
last week.
And what we're trying to do is
start off the conversation
about getting developers
excited about this API.
And then we'll start to build
out the patterns and practices
about how this should actually
be managed, from the
application layer, if
that makes sense.
So we're still early on.
And if you guys want to play
with it, you just email me
PaulKinlan@Google or catch
me pm Google+ or Twitter.
And we'll just try and do
another show where we'll
promote some of these things,
some of the stuff
that you do as well.
So that would be pretty cool.
But we need to know how you
want to use these things.
And the only way we'll know that
is by getting you guys to
experiment.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So I encourage
everyone to play.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
So we've got time for,
I think, about
one or two more questions.
Question was, does this work
over the internet?
Yeah, it absolutely would.
The one thing you have to be
aware of is that the network
socket that you're listening on
has to be connected to an
internet port, right.
So in our particular case, we're
listening to 127.0.0.1.
So we're listening for
our own loop back.
But Paul could have said hey,
what's the IP address on my
network port.
And I want to listen on that.
And then I could have, from here
in New York, connected to
him and been able to
listen to that.
But I would have had to been
able to get to his IP address.
PAUL KINLAN: It's the same as
just general networking, so it
should be fine.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Can we do one more question
or are we over time?
I think we're over time
now, aren't we?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I think we're
a little bit over time.
So with that, I want to say
thanks to Paul for joining me.
And thank you guys for
all joining us.
We'll be back next
week with another
installment of Chrome apps.
If there are things you want to
hear about, things you want
us to cover in more depth,
please be sure to reach out to
us, either through our own
Google+ pages-- i'm Pete
LePage or you can reach
to Paul Kinlan.
Or leave a comment in one of
our Google+ pages for the
Chrome developers.
So with that, Paul, I think
we should try for
another high five.
All right, ready?
PAUL KINLAN: Three, two, one.
PETE LEPAGE: Two, one, go.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: Yes.
That was --
PAUL KINLAN: That didn't work?
PETE LEPAGE: That was a lot
better than the first
time we tried it.
So all right, everybody.
Thanks very much.
Hope you have a wonderful day.
And talk to you soon.
Bye-bye.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]